ja ich begrüße zur heutigen sitzung in
der wir uns noch mal ganz kurz gedanken
machen wollen
zu diesem netten herrn hier mit dieser
schicken pfeife nämlich wird schon
wasser und bezüglich seine schriften auf
kos und im nachhinein habe ich den
eindruck gehabt dass dieser aufsatz sehr
wichtig ist obwohl seine these was man
noch mal seine these die wichtigste
these in diesem aufsatz oder seine
pointierte these wenn sie jetzt diesen
aufsatz den inhalt dieses aufsatzes
einen kommilitonen oder einer
kommilitonin mitteilen würden was würden
sie dann sagen warum ist dieser text
wichtig für die debatte für die frage
nach dem wesen der qualität was würden
sie sagen dass ist so mit einem satz was
ist die eine der wichtigsten thesen hier
aus diesem aufsatz was würden sie sagen
mit
ja genau also es kausalität dieser
begriff motion aufbaus der ist sinnlos
vielleicht oder jedenfalls hoch
problematisch das wäre eine mögliche
thesen als er sagt ja auch er muss
abgeschafft werden er ist ähnlich wie
die monarchie zu verstehen er kommt ja
aus großbritannien also da sagt das ist
ein relikt aus vergangenen zeiten
jetzt gibt es da einen sehr guten
übersichtsartikel von einem ehemals
tübinger philosophen der heißt michael
heidelberger wie die stadt und er hat er
hat ein aufsatz geschrieben kausalität
ein problem berichtet irgendwie sowas
ein problem übersicht diesen text habe
ich auch digitalisiert den mache ich
ihnen auch zugänglich und in diesem
aufsatz der ist sehr also gut geeignet
um so einen überblick geben zu bekommen
diesen aufsatz behandelt der
heidelberger auch die these von virgin
rasse sagt dann aber dass ungefähr seit
anfang der 80er jahre des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts sich eine trendwende
vollzogen hat wieder hin zur kausalität
also ungefähr mit 80er jahren redet man
in allen wissenschaften auch
naturwissenschaften eben wieder
verstärkt von kausalität wie es jetzt
momentan ist also in dem ersten zum
zweiten jahrzehnt des 21 jahrhunderts
weil sie nicht hundertprozentig aber ich
glaube es hat sich wieder ein bisschen
mehr verschoben in die richtung von
wasser also der qualitätsbegriff wird
gegenwärtig wieder stärker
problematisiert
es gibt immer wieder auf und ab also
dieser aufsatz von dem herrn
heidelberger der ist zu einer zeit
verfasst worden so anfang der 90er wo
kausalität wieder sehr prominent war und
was jetzt noch sagen wollte eine
unterscheidung die dieser autor hier
macht ist eine unterscheidung zwischen
generälen kausalität aussagen und
singulären kausalität aussagen das ist
auch noch ganz wichtig dass kamen wir
noch so im nachhinein singuläre leer
herr ochs aussagen und generelle was
könnte der unterschied zwischen diesen
zwei arten von 1000 urteilen haben sie
eine idee was könnte der unterschied
sein
das singuläre oder vielleicht auch
individuelle kausalität aussage wäre
eine aussage so und art oder wenn man
eine bestimmte ursache hat ein
bestimmtes ereignis hat was auch immer
gesagt mit dem demonstrativ von um
dieses war die ursache von jenem oder
von diesem also zb bringt jetzt
heidelberg in seinem aufsatz dieses
beispiel die einnahme dieser aspirin
tablette war ursächlich für die
linderung meiner kopfschmerzen sage ich
diese also diese tablette hier
diese was ist das problem von solchen
singulären aussagen das ist natürlich
eine kausalität aussage also wir können
über kausalität zu reden dass wir sagen
dieses etwas individuelles hätte auch
etwas singuläres nur dieses es gebe auf
der welt nur eine aspirin tablette
das hätte nur eine aspirin attackierte
auf der welt jemals gegeben nur eine
und die war sagen gegen kopfweh lindernd
für mich
richtig genau und jetzt sagen sie zu
recht wir begnügen uns nicht mit
singulär und qualitäts aussagen soll wir
wollen
generelle aussagen etwas wie gesetze aus
also wir können von kausalität schon so
reden wie mir scheint das so zu sagen
dieses ereignis war ursächlich für jenes
da brauchen wir keine gesetzmäßigkeit
eigentlich sagen dies war die ursache
von jenem und wir sind aber geneigt zu
sagen dieses diese aspirin tablette ist
einige instanz also ein fall von einem
tipp es gibt eben aspirin tabletten
das ist eine von unendlich vielen oder
von sehr vielen tabletten und jede
aspirin tablette hat diese wirkung und
dann kann nicht sagen also immer wenn
ich irgend eine aspirin tablette nehmen
dann kommt wird diese wirkung erzielen
ja richtig also gar erst er in tabletten
gestern hängt dann wiederum das kann man
zum nächsten problem von bestimmten
umständen ab
wenn ich zum beispiel dann noch alkohol
getrunken habe in diesem zeitraum oder
irgendwas anderes gemacht hat dann kann
die wirkung vielleicht nicht eintreten
und verspätet eintreten aber wir könnten
jetzt zum idealen szenario und werfen wo
sie immer wirken oder wo es eben ja wo
es sie immer gelten und dann hätten wir
das dass wir sagen könnten
es gibt hier so ein qualitäts gesetz
also alle aspirin tabletten immer wenn
ich irgend eine aspirin tabletten nehme
dann komme ich zu dieser wirkung
[Musik]
gute frage was glauben sie was glauben
sie ist ist für die generalität für die
gesetzmäßige aussage notwendig dass auch
die wirkung generell generalisiert wahr
ist oder was würden sie sagen genau
richtig aber mir scheint jetzt dass man
überhaupt fand generalität sprechen kann
kann es auch nur ein individuum sein
bezogen auf mich so auf mich aber eine
gute frage
also diese diese regatta auf auf denen
dann die wirkung zu trifft also das
sollte man nochmal unterscheiden und am
wasser hat jetzt hier eben ein
qualitätsbegriff vor augen der sehr
stark diese generellen qualitäts
beziehungen oder aussagen betrifft und
nicht individuell
das muss natürlich auch noch dazu sagen
also die frage ist ob gut wenn man von
kausalität selbst spricht das ist auch
wiederum zweideutig man kann sagen die
kausalität gesetz bedeutet alles was
geschieht geschieht nach einer
bestimmten ursache geschieht aufgrund
einer ursache das würde auch nur
singuläre kausalität aussagen wie mir
scheint betreffen können etwas anderes
ist denn wir nicht so was wie regula
rite neben behauptet die ich dann noch
stärker formuliere als gesetzmäßigkeit
als immer wenn ein typ ein instanz von
einem typ also ein ereignis was dann
wasser klein geschrieben hatte also ist
ein individuelles ereignis und ist der
typ des ereignis groß geschrieben also
wenn ich dann sage hier
dann ist die wirkung
dann haben wir eben hier die
gesetzmäßigkeit hier haben wir nur mit
blick auf ein individuum wobei allein
schon auch die rede von klein
eigentlich wieder schon so eine
generalität impliziert wir können
individualität nur ganz schlecht
symbolisieren wir sind im symbolisieren
wieder sehr schnell im generellen trend
des todes sagt das individuelle ist das
individuum ist unaussprechlich warum
sagte dass man ohne es auszusprechen
müssen wir begriffe anwenden und
begriffe sind immer allgemein immer
klassifizieren etwas zu finden an dem
wir es klassifizieren nehmen wir ihm
eigentlich seine individualität lassen
ist dann etwas werden von dem es
prinzipiell mehrere arten geben könnte
weil wir es untersucht so ein typus sind
ab 1 als begriffe gattungsbegriff
subsumieren
ja das ist jetzt der nächste punkt genau
oder sie an sich das war früher mit mit
diesem visa atomkatastrophe in
tschernobyl wo man sagte sein atomkraft
sondern atomkatastrophe kommen alle 1000
jahre vor
hatte man dann wieder ausgleichen
statistisch und dann kamen sie halt 50
jahre nach der zivilen nutzung vor und
also das ist ein wichtiger punkt mit
wahrscheinlichkeiten wir kommen da jetzt
heute gleich darauf zu sprechen wenn wir
uns mit diesen netten herrn wir mit
herrn reichenbach beschäftigen dessen
lebensdaten diesmal wirklich richtig
sein sollten also ich habe es wirklich
wer malz nachgeprüft also das ist glaube
ich richtig aber noch einmal ganz kurz
zur rasse zurück also der eine punkt den
sie richtig gesagt hatten war er sagt
kaus der qualitätsbegriff oder
kausalität ist eigentlich sinnlos
anzunehmen dass die hauptthese und die
begründung ist jetzt die die sie auch an
geführt hatten dass er sagt wir können
eigentlich nie so sprechen dass wir
sagen wir haben ja eine eigene stück und
dann kommt die wirkung ihrer wirkung
stück das ist immer schwierig weil wir
sollten eigentlich genau hinschauen wir
haben wir haben immer individuelle
ereignisse
er bringt als beispiel mehrere mehrere
szenarien er sagt einmal ein streichholz
anzünden und ein mal bringt er das
beispiel eine münze in ein automat
werfen und
jetzt muss man eben sagen es ist nicht
so dass es hier einfach der ereignis typ
festgelegt werden kann sondern und das
war jetzt ihr punkt wir müssen
eigentlich noch bestimmte
randbedingungen mit einbeziehen also es
gibt das sei ein ereignis das ereignis
sei eben dass wir ein streichholz
schreiben an dieser fläche dieses dieser
zündholzschachteln und dann müssen noch
bestimmte rahmenbedingungen mit eingehen
zb ja genau also das problem ist dass
ich formuliert jetzt mal so ich sag
jetzt mal
es sei dieser typ p das sei jetzt
einfach mal die tatsache dass ich also
ein streichholz an dieser reibefläche
treibe das einfach mal generell dieser
typ b und dann haben wir das so gesagt
haben müssen wir das mit einer
konjunktion machen und sie widersprechen
wir wenn sie dagegen ein wir haben also
diese ereignisse stattfinden dass der
typ des typus des schreibens dieses
streichholz an dieser schachteln muss da
sein und jetzt müssen sie ganz
verschiedene faktoren noch gegeben sein
das sind die umstands bedingungen damit
wir dann zu der neuerung kommen die
wirkung sei jetzt mein wegen des an das
brennen dieses streichholzes das
entzünden diese streich oder es ist also
ist ich reibe dieses streichholz an
dieser seite
das kann man ganz verschiedene faktoren
hier einbeziehen ja sie haben jetzt
schon was interessantes passieren wird
das fenster muss zu sein
also man kann jetzt zum beispiel hier
eigentlich und das problem man kann
jetzt in diese klamme unendlich viele
negative sachverhalte enthalten also zum
beispiel also nicht der fall dass das zb
nicht der fall dass der wind ist da
können sich unendlich viele dinge
überlegen ist es nicht der fall dass ein
erdbeben stattfindet er ist nicht der
fall dass eine atomrakete eigentlich ist
nicht der fall und so weiter und so fort
sie können eigentlich unendlich viel
negativer sachverhalte hier rein nehmen
das ist natürlich ein bisschen
problematisch also es gibt jetzt diese
negative bestimmung der sondern das darf
nicht sein das darf nicht sein das darf
nicht sein
oder wir können positive stimmung sagen
dass wir eben sagen gut es muss eine
bestimmte reibungs geschwindigkeit
gegeben sein
das streichholz muss trocken sein das
kann man auch wieder sofort darf nicht
feucht sein
das video ist eine negative sache eben
sein genau das kann man aber auch wieder
über so negatives sagt formulieren sie
bekommen da im endeffekt unendlich viele
faktoren rein also dass sie dann am ende
sich sagen müssten dann ist dieses
dieser eigenes stück gegenüber diesen
ganzen randbedingungen praktisch nicht
mehr hinreichend genau es notwendig dann
wird er notwendig aber nicht hinreichend
das ist ein guter punkt
und sie haben sich noch gemeldet
genauso viele
man kann jedes positive als negativ
formulieren genau wie unendlich ist aber
man kann eben jeden positiven faktor
eben auch als negativen als als die
negation von einem negativen faktor es
ist nicht feucht
ja man müsste eben
sie müssten faktoren seien also sind
alles hier faktoren faktoren die dann
zusammen mit das ganze hinreichend
werden lassen für wii oder da waren
es folgt das verwundert nicht wieder
aussagen bereit ist und dadurch die
ganze welt beschrieben hatte
und ich frage mich trotzdem dasselbe wie
es aus dem mehrere instanzen der selten
weil nicht die ganze welt beschrieben
ist also dass man die selbe bedingungen
zum zeitplan und dem beben bei genau das
könnte man genau das wollte ich damit
nichts sagen also man vielleicht ganz
kurz noch ganz kurz
so könnte man es vielleicht sagen ja
das erzwingen deswegen eben nicht weil
wir eben das noch also wir brauchen das
auf jeden fall ist es so wir haben hier
notwendig und die notwendigkeit
notwendige bedienen muss durch
zusätzliche faktoren zur hinreichend
bedingungen erhoben werden durch
zusätzliche faktoren was ich jetzt aber
noch sagen wollte ist folgendes ihr
punkt das verträgt sich wunderbar auch
mit seiner qualität seiner
gesetzmäßigkeit formulierung
deswegen habe ich jetzt auch mal groß
geschrieben dass die ich hatte mir erst
überlegt ob ich diese hier klein
schreiben sollen aber ich habe es groß
geschrieben also eben die pure
sachverhalt dass ein streichholz
gerieben wird an dieser fläche einfach
nur abstrakte sachverhalt eigentlich und
dann wären das hier nähere bestimmungen
dieses typs eigentlich dass wir also ein
ganz großes e hätten wir dann eigentlich
wir können diese ganzen rand faktoren
auch wiederum in so ein riesengroßes
einbeziehen das wird dann immer noch das
wird dann immer noch ein tipp sein aber
eben im endeffekt das sagt was im
endeffekt wenn das so komplex dann wenn
diese so komplex dass wir also alle
diese faktoren hier dass wir die alle
hier rein nehmen und dann so eine riesen
ii bekommen so sagen so ein riesen ehe
das dann eben am ende wenn die faktoren
so vielgestaltig sind wir gar nicht mehr
von einem typ sprechen können jedenfalls
von dem realen tag x der auf dieser welt
faktisch kontigent vorkommt aber logisch
gesehen könnte natürlich könnten wir
hier so viele randbedingungen rein
nehmen wir wollen
logisch gesehen ist es durchaus möglich
dass es zu einem typ wird das eben noch
mal so ein komplexer komplexes antigens
dieser dieser folge beziehung noch mal
auftritt
also auf dieser welt wahrscheinlich
nicht wenn wir jetzt hier 1000 faktoren
hier einbeziehen wenn das 1000 fraktion
braucht dann ist es wahrscheinlich als
leerfahrt zu unwahrscheinlich dass es
auf dieser welt jemals nochmal vorkommen
[Musik]
wenn wir ein anderes beispiel nicht
unbedingt das streichholz man könnte ich
mir noch was anderes nehmen aber es ist
trotzdem guter punkt wir könnten jetzt
irgendwas anderes nochmal konstruieren
wo wir könnten zum beispiel eine
maschine nehmen überlegen sie mal eine
maschine in das sie in eine maschine in
die sie eine münze einwerfen und sie
werfen jetzt diese münze diese konkrete
münze in diese maschine rein und dann
also die münze sie werfen diese münze 1
1 cent oder ein ein euro stück werfen
sie rein und dann fängt diese maschine
an irgendwie einen ton von sich zu geben
sie funktioniert haben und jetzt könnte
man sich vorstellen
sie werfen unendlich viele andere ein
euro stücke rein und das trifft aber
nicht auf das effekt weil diese maschine
eben sagen nur durch diese münze in gang
gesetzt werden konnte ich meine jetzt
eben nur wegen dieser beschaffenheit
dieser münzen nur aufgrund dieser
beschaffenheit demenz es waren also
kleine faktoren die sagen dann
letztendlich diese wirkung nämlich
dieses in gang setzen dieses gerät
bewirkt haben faktisch ist es natürlich
ziemlich unwahrscheinlich da haben sie
recht aber es letztlich ein fall
konstruieren wo wirklich diese diese
ganz kleinen bedingungen von einer münze
zb ist irgendwie wie viel sie genau
wiegt sie darf nur so und so viel wiegen
sie darf nicht ein milligramm er wegen
und ein milligramm weniger aber es ist
dieselbe münze letztendlich dieses typs
dann würde man wahrscheinlich am ende
auch gar nicht mehr sagen sie ist
irgendwie eine instanz dieses typs
sondern sie ist eben eine eigene
realität sein aber sie wird ja primär
fazit leben lebenswert ich sagen ich
werde dann euro rein und die maschine
ist eigentlich auch so konstruiert dass
sie nur ein euro stücke annimmt vom
schlitz wir haben ein euro rein und
genau diese ein-euro-münze setzt die
maschine gegangen sie werfen unendlich
andere euromünzen rein und sie setzen
damit die maschine nicht gegangen und
dann könnte man sich das ja so
konstruieren
aber sie haben natürlich recht im alltag
ist es so dass wir hier also fällen wie
streichholz anzünden dass wir da
natürlich hier als positive faktoren
hier nur wenige einsetzen müssen
und das ist in der regel klappt aber mit
dieser münze könnte man es eben jetzt so
konstruieren dass wenn ich mich nicht
irre das eben wirklich nur eine münze wo
sie sagen würde dass der typ ist ein
eine eine instanz dieses typs
ein-euro-münze wohl nur eine genommen
wird weil einfach die fakt weil die
maschine so eingestellt ist das eben nur
gerade diese diese einzelne münze
genommen wird und dann wäre es aber
logisch trotzdem möglich dass es noch
mal funktioniert wenn sie eben genau
dieselbe würden sie noch mal hätten und
das ist ja logisch nicht ausgeschlossen
sie können zum beispiel sagen diese
münze ist oder diese maschine ist
sensitive für eine eine gewichts größe
im zehnten nachkomme
dann haben sie können sie das mit ganz
hoch entwickelten verfahren noch einmal
schaffen und logisch gesehen sowieso
wenn sie jetzt natürlich sagen es ist
sagen es ist so eine feinheit erfordert
es ist so eine differenz erfordert die
irgendwie ins unendliche geht könnte man
sich auch konstruieren das ist so eine
ganz ganz unendlich fast schon unendlich
minimale gewichtigkeit die man
vielleicht nie wieder herstellen wird
können dann nicht aber noch ein logisch
ist es möglichst noch mal herzustellen
es war aber noch nicht
im kreis weil wir jetzt wieder bergauf
unserer jahren das ist doch schon im
nächsten kreistag
generation geschichte
wenn die schon risiko gebe noch 13
ein
[Musik]
nicht richtig pragmatisch wenn also
wasser war insofern komme gleich
aussieht so bedeutsam als ein antritt
denke nämlich dieser john leslie mecki
schreiben auch mal hin dass diese mecki
der hat dann hier angesetzt an diesen an
diesen an diesen faktoren und hat dann
eine sogenannte - bedingung
und jedes ist also ein akronym und jeder
dieser buchstabe bedeutet eine bedingung
also ist inzwischen und mindestens serry
und so weiter und so fort und hat
praktisch hier dieses dieses alte cds
dieser implikationen hat er diesen
diesem bereich hier hat er weiter
analysiert und er verdankt aber diese
weitere analyse eigentlich wenn ich es
recht dieser diesem hinweis kann wird
von grasser dass wir einfach hier in der
regel noch weitere faktoren mit rein
nehmen müssen und es sind nicht so viele
das sind nicht so viele konkret gesehen
leben es wird jetzt haben sie sich etwas
und was wirkung ist
viele sachen sind ja kontext und
verletzt haben
da bleibt ungewiss so sagt
google könnte was war das erste
das ist jetzt aber ja auch gar nicht
unbedingt so richtig wenn man könnte ja
aus dieser ganzen kausalität kette im
einen herausgreifen und relativ gesehen
zu einem was ein ereignis was darauf
folgt ist eben das vorhergehende die
ursache es kann dann wiederum relativ so
etwas was ihm vorher ging die wirkung
zahlen also dass man nimmt sich nur
seinen zeit einen bestimmten
zeitabschnitt raus eine konstellation ja
aber wir schauen wir beobachten einfach
dass jetzt ein bestimmtes ereignis ein
anderes ereignis hervorbringt wir gehen
davon aus dass das kausal sei
und dann können wir einfach die ganze
vorgeschichte erste ausklammern gesagt
einfach ich meine guten zum beispiel ist
dieses beispiel mit diesem einwerfen der
münze natürlich ist auch mein einwerfen
der münze wenn wir jetzt von seiner
streng kausalen geschlossenheit ausgehen
der welt auch durch andere ereignisse
kausal bedingt so dass ich das jetzt
machen aber das ist doch jetzt
eigentlich für das einwerfen der münze
ist interessant ich hatte
[Musik]
ach so sie meinen also dass dein eigenes
typ dass wir den als solche überhaupt
identifizieren können also die
identifizierung des ereignisses okay
gutes wird es nicht
ja aber sie bringen einen guten punkt
ins spiel nämlich und das ist der letzte
punkt den ich jetzt was sagen möchte
nämlich die frage nach der ereignisse
also die frage nach der ontologie der
ursachen und das ist glaube ich ein
weiterer wichtiger punkt in vrasselt
verdanken also lassen wir verdanken
russell einmal dass er zeigt es gibt so
ante cds also dieses dieser teil vor
diesem fall bedingungen hier diesen teil
die wir komplexer gestalten müssen dass
er hinweist auf krücken auf ereignis
typen und ereignis vorkommnisse also
diese kleine nies und dann ist aber ganz
wichtig dass er sagt und dass wir daraus
den schluss ziehen könnt dass wir uns
über die ontologie dieser ursachen noch
mal genauere gedanken machen müssen
und jetzt ist hier die frage wie fein
könig müssen ursachen bestimmt das sein
vielleicht erinnern sie sich an diesen
artikel den ich ihnen zu beginn auch mal
hier präsentierte aus der stanford pedy
auszufliegen
das ist ein sehr guter auftritt gewesen
auf englisch über kausalität und da war
einer dieser punkte ist sei eine frage
der debatte wie feinkörnig ursachen
bestimmt werden müssen
und und russell sagte wir können die
unter logi der ursache nicht im sinne
der prozess als prozess bestimmt und hat
deswegen weil sie sagen eine ursache sei
ein prozess wiederum eigentlich
ursächlichkeit impliziert prozesses sind
in sich kausal strukturiert sie sind
komplexe von kleineren ereignissen
das heißt russell scheidet jetzt einmal
die prozesse aus dann sagt er so ein
ereignis geht eigentlich auch nur sehr
schlecht weil wir eben auch die
randbedingungen rheine müssen und
randbedingungen sind eigentlich kein
ereignis also randbedingungen sind
eigentlich ja umstände jetzt und jetzt
ist der punkt
jetzt gibt es verschiedene möglichkeiten
wie wir auf dieses problem antworten
können dinge schließt er sowieso aus
also diese heidelberger den ich hier
vorn angeschrieben hatte schreibt in
seinem aufsatz bis ab dem 18 jahrhundert
redete man nicht mehr von substanzen
oder von dingen als ursache oder wirkt
beim anerkannt gibt es noch eine stelle
wo er davon spricht die substanz
wechselt als die substanz führt eine
änderung der der aktie dance sich
akzidenzen herbei als er da ist noch so
eine art von unter logischer rede aber
dinge sind eigentlich seit dem 18
jahrhundert nicht mehr möglich
kandidaten verursachen bekommt schon
jetzt hatten wir da eine möglichkeit ins
auge gefasst wie wir dieses problem
lösen können dass wir praktisch alle
diese bedingungen hier in ein großes e
rein tun können
wir hatten wir das versucht zu lösen
indem sie sich noch an die letzte
sitzung
was hatten wir dann gesagt wir sollten
nicht von prozess sprechen wir sollten
nicht von ereignis sprechen weil das
ereignis hier die ganzen land faktoren
noch mit pz was hatten wir stattdessen
gesagt ja
situation genau oder tatsache wobei das
problem bei einer tatsache ist es wir
müssten dann strengen und meiner
tatsache auch sagen es ist die tatsache
dass hier das ist dass wir die münze
einwerfen und es ist die tatsache dazu
müssen auch noch ganz viele andere
tatsachen in zukunft nämlich die
tatsache dass diese wahlen rand
bedingung erfüllt ist dass dieser dem
erfüllt was dies wir können natürlich
sagen wir packen alle randbedingungen
und dieses ereignis in so eine große
tatsache rhein ist es einfach diese
tatsache aber da ist eben situationen
finde ich besser ist es die situation
es sind diese umstände als es tritt auf
der ereignisse das schreiben eines
streichholzes ammann diese reibefläche
dann tritt diese andere bedingungen
bestimmte geschwindigkeit mit der das
geschrieben wird wenn sie ganz langsam
das streichholz reiben an der fläche
passiert nichts sie müssen bestimmte
kritische geschwindigkeit erreichen mit
und auch der druck es darf nicht so
leicht sein es darf nicht zu stark sein
wenn sie zu stark ist schon bestimmten
häufig vorgekommen
ein bericht des streichens ab wenn sie
das zu starten
alle diese ganzen faktoren rein und mir
scheint jetzt einer der besten
kandidaten eben der der situation zu
sein
was sagen sie zur situationsanalyse
ich habe ein problem mit der situation
dazu da
sie können jedenfalls die situation
konkret angeben sie können sagen
situation bestimmt diesen diesen diesen
faktoren
ich habe ein problem mit der situation
mir scheint die situation so ein
bisschen zirkuliert zu sein das ist ein
bisschen mein verdacht den ich da habe
auch die rede von tatsachen dass damit
schon vorausgesetzt wird dass es kausal
wirksam ist
das wollen wir doch gerade zeigen also
was wir durch situationen lösen können
ist dass wir diese ganzen bedingungen
ketten in dieses eine ereignis rein tun
können so können wir das sagen hat ist
eine situation ein ereignis wenn sie
sagen eigentlich nicht gern nicht ist
kein ereignis
genau und er sagt dann eben das in
dieser zeitspanne verschiedene andere
dinge eintreten könnten
das sagte auch genau und das können wir
eben durch die situation lösen das kann
man lösen durch die sie durch den
begriff der situation können wir
verhindern dass sich zwischen ursache
und wirkung noch mal randbedingungen
einschleichen sozusagen mit der
situation eigentlich das ganze an tcd
ins angegeben haben
aber das scheint mir ist ein bisschen
zirkuliert zu sein
also wir kriegen wir kriegen daraus
diese wir machen nur eine analyse
letztendlich des begriffs von von
ursächlichkeit was wir damit vor
aussetzen müssen wir begründen die die
ursächlichkeit damit eigentlich nicht
das ist so ein bisschen mein problem ist
damit habe
[Musik]
ja es war ein gutes problem dass er
sagte dass also sagen die anti cds
bedingungen dass die nicht so
unmittelbar ins nächste platzen sollen
[Musik]
dynamisches prozesshafte sind
als ich glaube dass wir mit der
situation dieses explosions problem
lösen können also ich glaube dass das
nicht das problem ist die situation kann
auch prozesse implizieren dass er die
situation es sind die ganzen bedingungen
die eben des erzählens konzentriert ist
eine analytische ereignis genau die
situation gibt der begriff der situation
ist in meinen augen indifferent
gegenüber der statik und dynamik wir
können einfach sagen wir nennen es das
ganze was vor diesem fall steht also
hier kommt dann die wirkung noch immer
meinen alles alles situation packen alle
sind die situation rein da kann dann
beliebig viel variieren dran aber wir
haben jetzt nur die generelle
klassifizierung als situationen zu so
einem ereignis
wir waren beim ereignis müssen eben noch
die ganzen hand bedingungen mit
eingegeben werden
nein die randbedingungen sind schon drin
die situation ist die situation ist die
konjunktion des ereignisses und der an
mit dem das heißt da haben wir alles in
zum gesamtpaket und zwar mit den
einzelnen begriff gefasst ich habe aber
auch meine probleme mit dem situations
begriff bisschen mir scheint es eben nur
eine analytische beschreibung zu sein
eine tatsache die tatsache dass das so
und so und so ist okay aber folgt daraus
den warum folgt dann aus die situation
dann die wirkung sei es muss so eine
situation geben und sie haben sie noch
gemeldet
die situation spezifisches frage ob
situation vorgibt und die anderen
institutionen existiert nichts 100
nämlich davon dass institutionen als
revolution also das von ihr und könnte
den augen passierte
ein teil
als ich stelle mir das so vor
sie haben hier verschiedene sachverhalte
oder tatsachen oder fakten und der welt
und sie sagen einfach das hier ist jetzt
die situation und diese situation bringt
diese situation hier hervor ja es
richtig die frage wie wir mit der
situation festlegen
das scheint ganz stark von unserer
erkenntnistheorie von unserem
erkenntnistheoretischen zugang abhängig
zu sein
systemische systemische sache bisschen
willkürlich aber es geht so eine
klassifizierung ist wenn man nur auf
begrifflicher ebene nur mal vor zeugen
sowohl jetzt gar nicht sagen was war
jetzt wirklich hier die rahmenbedingung
rein angenommen wir wüssten einfach mal
vorausgesetzt wir wüssten sie wie nennen
wir das ganze dann und gästen wie
sollten wir es betitelt wie ich begriff
und da ist für mich gibt der situation
eigentlich ein ziemlich guter kandidat
weil er viele probleme lösen kann auf
einen begrifflicher ebene sie gerade
noch dazu
dazu
schön gebeutelt
aber das muss das grip muss trotzdem
irgendwann realität werden
solche tricks kontinent
dann wenn die edle unterschiedliche
theologische zustände haben
das ist eine menschengemachte geringsten
weil es ja nicht anders nur träumen
können sondern etwas darauf tatsächlich
also eine mögliche veränderung der welt
statt
das andere also die land bedingungen
also dass das will ich gar nicht
bestreiten also diese rede von situation
ist sehr problematisch noch bevor sie
haben noch zwei meldung erst ganz hinter
und sie ist ganz nicht mehr
ach so ja dann haben hätten wir eben
keine regelmäßigkeit das stimmt ja wobei
man ja alle das wie gesagt das ist hier
das problem dieser großen großen klammer
der randbedingungen aber meine
vorschläge situation ist wir können die
randbedingungen sehr groß machen wir
hätten jedenfalls für individuelle der
singuläre kausalität aussagen hätten wir
jedenfalls dann mit der situation genug
und wir können uns eine mögliche welt
vorstellen in der eben auch wieder alles
vom urknall aus beginnt logisch möglich
ist es dass wir eine identische welt
haben die genau so abläuft wie unsere
welt in einem anderen universum als
logisch möglich und dann könnten wir
eben wieder sagen dann haben wir ein
gesetz aussage auf unsere welt
jedenfalls nicht auf unserer welt wird
das nicht nochmal vorkommen wenn es
einmal so wirklich gewesen ist von und
eben die randbedingungen bis zum urknall
impliziert aber vielleicht von der
antritt logisch möglich ist es in meinen
augen nach leibnitz jetzt logischen
mögliche welt
jetzt hatten sie sich noch gemeldet
schritt gemacht aber wenn ich bin ich
jetzt durch diese habe man verlieren
kann
bundes- und sich als verspannt
inzwischen stehen und die ganzen
randbedingungen gesteckt hat alles in
diesen breiten und das ist damit größer
sagt
aber eigentlich interessiere ich mich
für das eben auch nicht für das e
die alle oben platz zwei war also gut
meine seine kollegen nicht
nicht das eigentliche was
prognostizieren wissen aus den
ereignissen in der regel jedoch über die
wirkung wäre das ist völlig richtig und
er sagt in seinem aufsatz das wenn diese
bedingung so komplex werden wir keine
wissenschaftlich sinnvoll aussagen
machen können einfach zu viele faktoren
mit ein
[Musik]
ja - und das heißt nichts anderes als
das was sein
stimmt das
das muss ja aber wenn wir zum beispiel
sagen hier kein wind kein wind und die
muss man zweimal zeichen dieses ziels
und zwar ist das jetzt der zustand dann
richtig das ereignis statt für das liga
und rechts leben muss das spiel den
zustand des leh bevor die wirkung
eingetreten ist okay ich hatte das jetzt
ich hatte mir den kriegen er situationen
gemeint ja ok ja ja sie denken jetzt
sind sie wie sie sagen jetzt zu recht
wir brauchen hier eigentlich eine
ontologische dimension wieder das ist
auch bei mir immer so ein bisschen mein
problem weil sie mit dieser rede von
ereignissen habe ereignis geht dann ganz
schnell so die richtung ist eine
tatsache ist eine tatsache die tatsache
dass dieses ereignis eintritt und da
fehlt mir so ein bisschen die
ontologische komponente oder auch die
physikalischen wie auch immer diese
wirkt komponente wir machen einfach nur
ist eine tatsache beschreibung das und
damit verlieren wir in meinen augen ist
ein bisschen dieses problem dieser kraft
die da in der kausalität enthalten ist
diese notwendigkeit mehr sagen darüber
nichts aus über diese notwendigkeit der
kausalität redaktion sondern wir legen
wir setzen sie voraussagen ja gut das
ist eben notwendig dann dafür
hinreichend wie auch immer aber wir
beschreiben diese notwendigkeit nicht
mehr sind wir sagen nur was der fall
sein muss oder wie wir das beschreiben
müssten mit begriffen wenn es notwendig
oder hinreichend ist aber diese kausale
kraft selbst die analysieren wird
dadurch nicht genau das ist so ein
bisschen das problem dieser ganzen rede
von tatsachen und von ereignissen die
rede von substanzen hingegen
theologische rede mit kräften die wird
unsere intuition mehr gerecht wenn es
darum geht diese notwendigkeit der
kausalität relation zu verstehen da gibt
es einfach physikalisch
krafteinwirkungen da haben wir diese
diesen diesen sinn von kausalität in
diesem beispiel enthalten als die bloße
sprach philosophische re formulierung
diese bedingungen
das ist so ein bisschen ein problem was
ich auch damit haben wird alles so sehr
auf diese sprachliche ebene berichtet
noch ganz kurz dazu eine geber weiter
her
lesen macht
ja dass der in richtung versucht hatte
komponente des begriffs zweiten über das
eine richtungslose
dann haben die aktionäre wichtig das ist
das ist dann als er im sommer genau also
ernst mache ich sehr abhängig von der
youtube also auch als es auch so ein mp
rio kritik es ist also empirisch heißt
er geht einfach davon aus was können wir
beobachten und versuchen das funktional
darzustellen auch bei juris muss geht so
in diese ecke es wird einfach nur dann
quantifiziert aber da verlieren wir hat
auch wiederum diesen starken begriff der
ursächlichkeit der notwendigkeit wenn
man es nur in funktionen machen wenn das
dann das also wie gesagt ich wollte nur
darauf hinweisen dass wir damit auch ein
bisschen was verlieren von unserer
intuition des qualitätsbegriff so jetzt
haben wir noch mal lange herum geredet
aber ich glaube es war wichtig weil
dieser aufsatz zu provokativ auch ist
und vielleicht manchen stellen auch zu
unklar ist doch wichtige problempunkte
aufgezeigt hat jetzt die ganze sprach
philosophische debatte dominieren also
mit russell beginnt eigentlich könnte
man sagen nicht mehr die psychologische
frage nach der qualität die wir bei
david jung zum beispiel haben auch noch
ein bisschen bei kant auch nicht mehr
die ontologische die wir davor hatten
vielleicht bei platon werden oder bei
hemden schopenhauer scheint man auch ein
bisschen unter logische rede noch
gewesen sondern sind jetzt geht es um
die logische sprach philosophische
formulierung aber jetzt haben wir hier
noch einen anderen kandidaten nämlich
hier diesen hans reichenbach der
versucht jetzt kausalität und
wahrscheinlichkeit mann ein verhältnis
zu bringen und hier haben wir wieder so
ein paar fragen nämlich wie verhalten
sich nach reichenbach kausalität und
wahrscheinlichkeit zueinander wie
vermöchte reichenbach den
wahrscheinlichkeit begriff verteidigen
wie verhalten sich logik und
wahrscheinlichkeit theorie oder
wahrscheinlichkeit zueinander und wie
verhalten sich wahrscheinlichkeit und
induktion
sondern der alte des induktions problem
was sie ja von der jugend kennen wir
haben eben eine endliche anzahl von
beobachteten regelmäßigkeiten und wir
schließen daraus auf eine
gesetzmäßigkeit also etwas das es
vielleicht immer so ist oder immer in
der zukunft was generell ist als von
einer begrenzten endlichen anzahl auf
etwas prinzipiell unendliches das ist
das problem der induktion und dass wir
hier auch noch behandeln also ich muss
dazu sagen wenn sie jetzt noch mal hier
diese geburtsdaten anschauen also 891
unzureichend nachwächst in einer zeit
auf wo eben die ganzen revolutionären
erkenntnisse der physik stattgefunden
haben zu wissen wann albert einstein die
spezielle relativitätstheorie formuliert
hat wissen sie dieses jahr zum beispiel
noch ich weiß es zufälligerweise weil
ich eben jetzt ein seminar über zeit und
da habe ich mich damit beschäftigt ja ja
das war die das war eine andere zahl die
auch ganz wichtig ist es ist ein
bisschen früher sogar es ist 1905 und
das ist das sogenannte anders anders
mirabilis das wunder jahren es gibt wenn
sie mal auf wikipedia schauen annus
mirabilis eingeben es gibt verschiedene
sagen an ihm die rabbis es gibt viele
wunder jahre davor natürlich wo ganz
unter was wurde dort entdeckt
na ja genau also newton ist natürlich
ganz wichtig ist richtig dann galileo
galilei diese gravitationsgesetz die da
formuliert wurden von juden wurden sie
denn mathematisch modelliert also es
gibt ganz viele sind also jahre in denen
sich besonders viele wichtige
erkenntnisse ereignet haben in einer
bestimmten disziplin und 1905 war das
eben durch albert einstein er hat in
diesem jahr vier aufsätze geschrieben
das ist unglaublich und ein forscher hat
einmal gemeint für jeden dieser aufsätze
hätte albert einstein eigentlich den
eine einen separaten nobelpreis verdient
und er hat dann einen aufsatz
geschrieben 1905 eben einer dieser vier
und einer war eben über elektro dynamik
also über bewegte systeme und die
relativität der zeit dass in bewegten
systemen die zeit langsamer verläuft und
dass die lichtgeschwindigkeit hat er
eben angenommen das war eine vermutung
ist es war noch nicht bewiesen sondern
es war eher eine vermutung von ihnen
dass die lichtgeschwindigkeit in allen
systemen konstant ist auch in bewegten
system sie könnten sich ja vorstellen
also sie kennen ja alle dass wenn sie
zum beispiel aus einem flugzeug heraus
in der rakete abschießen also bewegten
flugzeug heraus dann addieren sich die
geschwindigkeiten aufeinander dh die
rakete fliegt mit ihrer geschwindigkeit
plus der geschwindigkeit mit der sie im
flugzeug schon davor bewegt wurde
das ist ganz interessant und jetzt sagt
albert einstein für eine lichtquelle
gilt es nicht als wenn sie jetzt eine
glühbirne ganz schnell bewegen in eine
richtung
sie müssen davon ausgehen im club eine
sendet permanent sofort ohne maus
lichtteilchen mit lichtgeschwindigkeit
dann addiert sich die
bewegungsgeschwindigkeit der glühbirne
nicht noch auf die richtgeschwindigkeit
hinzu das heißt egal wie schnell sie die
glühbirne bewegung im raum das licht
wird dadurch nicht schneller
die lichtgeschwindigkeit ist konstant
bei drei ungefähr 300.000 km pro sekunde
und albert einstein hat eben in diesem
aufsatz da eben ganz interessante also
ein schlussfolgerung gezogen dass eben
die zeit abhängig ist von der
geschwindigkeit und natürlich auch die
es gibt einen längeren kontraktion es
gibt mit zeit kontraktion und ich wollte
es jetzt nur als beispiel bringt da war
jetzt hans reichenbach nur 14 jahre alt
aber bis die wahrscheinlichkeit theorie
und dann gab es natürlich noch die das
ist jetzt nur die spezielle
relativitätstheorie 1905 formuliert war
es gab da natürlich auch noch die
allgemeine relativitätstheorie und die
ist dann bisschen später formuliert
worden
in den zehn jahren dann ich glaube nur
16 oder zone also ein bisschen später 17
uhr so da hat eben albert einstein
gezeigt dass er seine ganzen aussagen
nicht nur auf gleichförmig bewegte
systeme beziehen kann so oft
beschleunigte systeme also oder
beschleunigungskräfte wirken 905 hat er
noch nichts gesagt über systeme die
jetzt beschleunigt werden da spielt
jetzt die gravitation oder sowas gar
keine rolle da geht man davon aus dass
die systeme sich konstant bewegen
jedenfalls da sehen sie da war der
antrag schon ein bisschen älter waren
die 25 rom und da hatte dann studiere
ich wollte damit sagen es gibt so eine
ganze generation von denkern und
philosophen die sich dann auch später
wissenschaftstheoretiker genannt haben
für die eben diese ganzen neuen
erkenntnisse sehr bedeutend waren
leider musste hans reich brachten wie
viele andere intellektuelle dieser zeit
migrieren also wenn sie dann mal schauen
immer wo sind die geborenen sie irgendwo
in deutschland geboren und in österreich
und wo sind sie gestorben irgendwo in
kalifornien das ist so eine ganze
generation also ein typischer werdegang
die mussten leider alle also eben
deutschland verlassen
aufgrund von verschiedenen faktoren die
eben dem system damals nicht passten dh
die ganze wissenschaftstheorie ist
eigentlich seien die usa nach england
ausgewandert
diesen aufsatz jetzt von 1930 hatte aber
noch wie sie sehen hier auf deutsch
geschrieben also 30 war noch nicht so
ein schlimmes jahr und also das ist in
der zeitschrift erkenntnis erschienen
und zwar in der ersten ausgabe der
zeitschrift erkenntnis von der auch hans
reichenbach einer der mitherausgeber war
und die zeitschrift erkenntnis gibt es
immer noch können sie mal googeln und da
erscheint immer noch auf sie zu tun und
zwar wenn nicht alles täuscht für die
sogar auch hier in münchen herausgegeben
oder ganz zentral von einigen hier
lehrenden philosophen wie dem hannes
leitgeb oder dem herrn hartmann stefan
hartmann mit diese zeitschrift läuft
besonders betreut und wir haben also
viele experten die sich gerade mit
solchen dingen wie hans reisen
reichenbach beschäftigen also 1930 war
die philosophie so weit dass sie sich
mit diesen erkenntnissen dieser
revolutionären entdeckung von albert
einstein und anderen er war ja nicht der
einzige richtig auch philosophisch
beschäftigen konnten das war so die zeit
das wollte ich jetzt nur kurz erwähnen
und jetzt haben wir irgendwie leitfragen
es geht darum wie kausalität und
wahrscheinlichkeit einer zusammenhänge
sagt er wir gehen einfach mal so ein
bisschen durch gesagt die gegenwärtige
erkenntnistheoretische situation der
physik welche in der quantenmechanik zu
zweifeln an der unumschränkten
gültigkeit des kausal prinzips geführt
hat ist er anders geworden dass man sich
auch in weiten weiten kreisen für das
qualitäts kausal problem stärker als sie
interessiert dass man von einer krise
der kausalität gesprochen hat daher
kommen natürlich noch weitere kenntnisse
dazu die quantenphysik da ist dann zu
nennen heisenberg und andere dass man
eben zeigt dass im sehr sehr kleinen
ebenso wie kausal relation gar nicht
mehr erkennbar sind oder vielleicht auch
und theologisch gar nicht mehr geltend
dass man da eben nur noch mit
wahrscheinlichkeit verhältnissen rechnen
kann das auch noch ein wichtiger punkt
wenn man in der tat heute einen solchen
besonderen anlass hat wenn man es
zugleich als eine erfreuliche auswirkung
der gegenwärtigen versieht bezeichnen
darf dass ihre grundlagen probleme über
den kreis der fachklassen hinaus
öffentliches interesse erregt und neue
impulse in eine wissenschaft allgemeinen
charakters in die erkenntnistheorie
hinaus tragen so darf man doch nicht
vergessen dass die
erkenntnistheoretische problemlage der
quantenmechanik keineswegs eine
isolierte situation darstellt dass sie
viel mehr durchaus eingebettet ist ein
historisch entwicklung die schon mehr
als 100 jahre zurückreicht und deren
konsequente weiterführung und vielleicht
vollendung wir gegenwärtig erleben dem
der einzug des wahrscheinlichkeit
begriffs in die physik liegt schon um
solche zeiträume zurück also reichenbach
möchte jetzt so ein bisschen die
wahrscheinlichkeit theorie verteidigen
gegenüber der alltäglichen oder
umgangssprachlichen vorwürfen dass doch
wahrscheinlichkeit gar keine bedeutung
hätte und jetzt sagt er folgendes auf
759 es ist das unheil des
wahrscheinlichkeit begriffs das ihm seit
seiner wissenschaftlichen geburt ein
makel anhaftet der marke des fuhren
vollkommen und spielerischen zugleich
des unvollkommenen denen man hat die
wahrscheinlichkeit gesetze immer nur als
etwas behelfsmäßige sun sehen wollen
dass neben dem großen bruder der
kausalität nur eine ausflucht
menschlicher unwissenheit darstellt und
sich mit ihm an sicherheit und
erkenntnistheoretische tiefe nicht
messen kann und es spielerischen die
schuld daran trug vor allem das erste
mathematische aufblühen des
wahrscheinlichkeit begriffs das an die
theorie der glücksspiele gebunden war
und den wahrscheinlichkeit plus als eine
geistvolle mathematische aushilfe für
probleme erscheinen ließ die er für sich
inhaltlich zu uninteressant waren um
eine tiefere physikalische durchdringung
zu verdienen was sagte jetzt hier was
das problem des wahrscheinlichkeit
betrifft
ja deshalb
ich möchte ganz gern wird sich ganz den
kinos kommen
[Musik]
hält die sozusagen genau
nun sagt er
zeitgleich wollte ich nicht bekommen
alle zahlen kann nicht gleich so viel
das ist da
denn
er selbst unterliege aber es ist es erst
möglich und auch im ersten
genau wissen und verließ schaden das ist
der anspruch nimmt
im grunde ja also das ist ein guter
punkt am jedenfalls fiel gleich können
wir sagen wir haben es wird in uns etwas
eine frage erstmal unbeantwortet
gelassen
prima vaart sie wenn wir zum beispiel
das sagen die wahrscheinlichkeit ist
irgendwie einen sechsten oder so wir
wollen eigentlich nie nur
wahrscheinlichkeiten haben sind wir
wollen wo die wahrscheinlichkeit geht an
1 es geht also jemand eins wenn wir eben
unendlich finale da würfeln oder so wir
wollen ihnen die 1 haben wir wollen
nicht geht gegen eins oder so haben wir
wollen die einst haben und zwar gleich
wir wollen nicht irgendwie daheim ran da
würfeln wollen sondern wir wollen ist
sofort haben
und wenn ich jetzt reichen war recht
verstehe versuchte das ganze jetzt ein
bisschen mehr zu begründen als er will
zeigen dass wir eben wahrscheinlich von
wahrscheinlichkeit durchaus sehr
objektiv reden können und dass sie für
uns auch im kontext der kausalität
problematik was sehr wichtiges ist
bindet das ganze dann zurück an die
physikalische sachverhalte jetzt sagt er
zum beispiel im nächsten zitat heute
besitzt ja die anwendung des
wahrscheinlichkeit begriffs der theorie
der glücksspiele nur noch die bedeutung
einer durchsichtigen veranschaulichung
des mathematischen algorithmus der
wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung ohne dass
doch der begriff sich von dem ihm seit
damals anhaftenden odium des
spielerischen in ganz befreit hätte und
doch muss die nachfolge entwicklung
angesehen werden als ein ein dringendes
wahrscheinlichkeit begriff sind immer
wichtigeren tiefere sphären der physik
natur kenntnis erkenntnis überhaupt
schon der ausbau der fehler theorie
zeigte dass die anlässlich der
glücksspiele getriebenen mathematischer
studien eine fruchtbare anwendung auf
ernste wird naturwissenschaftliche
probleme ermöglicht hier erschien der
wahrscheinlichkeit griff zum ersten mal
in der physik selbst wenn auch zunächst
nur als eine kultur der messgenauigkeit
von
ansich kausalen gesetzt also bei
reichenbach kommt jetzt hier kommen
jetzt mehrere faktoren ins spiel
man nennt jetzt diese philosophen wie
hans reichenbach einer ist es gibt da
noch ganz viele andere sie haben
bestimmt schon mal was vom wiener kreis
gehört der kreis das war auch ein kreis
von sogenannten wissenschaftstheoretiker
oder wissenschafts philosophen die haben
einfach gesehen es gibt so bedeutende
entwicklungen der naturwissenschaft wie
die allgemeine spezielle
relativitätstheorie wie die
quantenphysik wie diese ganzen sonstigen
theorien jetzt von reisen der die
unschärferelation usw sofort dass wir
einfach so eine art von
interdisziplinärer philosophie
entwickeln müssen der wiener kreis
können sie mir davon vielleicht noch
einen nennen von dem wiener kreis und
moritz schlick genauer noch in anderen
jahr genau der karl popper den haben sie
bestimmt schon mal gehört genau genau
rudolf karnap ist auch ein ganz
wichtiger denker und es gab dann einen
anderen philosophen der hieß wo es ganz
stegmüller und er wurde vom stegmüller
hat ganz lange in münchen gelehrt der
hat diese ganze sie kennen ja diese
fakultät für philosophie
wissenschaftstheorie
religionswissenschaft fakultät 10 und
unsere fakultät und das die auch
wissenschaftstheorie in sich hat
verdanken wir diesen wolfgang stegmüller
der einschüler dieser wiener kreis leute
war die leider eben auch so größten teil
aller dann in die ins exil mussten in
den dreißigerjahren und dieser im
reichenbach gehört jetzt nicht zu dem
wiener kreis sondern gehört dem berliner
kreis gab als auch eine berliner schule
es gibt ein wiener schule und der
berliner schule
worin die sich jetzt genau unterscheiden
eine spannende frage vielleicht könnte
man noch sagen dass der wiener kreis das
ist von vermutung dass der auch ein ganz
starkes sozial philosophischen interesse
hat also der wiener kreis war nicht nur
beschränkt auf jetzt
also die theoretische physik hat immer
versucht auch so die angrenzenden
bereiche mit einzubeziehen
moritz schlick am wurde schon genannt so
könnte man es vielleicht sagen
vielleicht war der berliner kreisen ein
bisschen auch mathematischer
interessiert als der wiener kreis war
das ist nur eine vermutung
jedenfalls haben beide großen städte bei
der haupt große tradition in der physik
vor allem natürlich auch der wiener
krieg heiß wenn sie an den philosophen
ernst macht denken der auch veralbert 1
stand übrigens von ganz großer bedeutung
war und ernst mach wiederum ist von
david hume sehr stark beeinflusst
gewesen als sie sehen hier kommt
plötzlich weitere disziplin ins spiel
ist sehr interdisziplinär und jetzt
gehen wir mal kurz weiter
genau ich lese mal kurz vor nachdem die
parallelität von wahrscheinlichkeit
gesetzen und kausal gesetzen ist ganz
wichtig sind parallel wer einmal erkannt
war tauchte schon bald innerhalb der
physik die frage auf nach der
erkenntnistheoretischen rangordnung
dieser beide gesetz begrenzt begriffe
die einen hielten den kausal begriffe
den primären sie glauben welche
auffassung die idealistische philosophie
seit kann sicherlich eine rolle spielt
dass letzten endes kausal gesetze das
weltgeschehen regieren
wahrscheinlichkeit gesetze nur dann
angewendet dürfen wenn die genaue
erfassung der natur vorgehen im
einzelnen aus technischen gründen nicht
möglich ist nach dieser auffassung ist
das geschehen in kleinen durch strenge
kausal gesetze bestimmt nur für das
geschehen im großen wenn der mensch
wahrscheinlichkeit gesetz an weil die
strenge behandlung eines systems das
sich jeder makroskopische körper also
eine ungeheure und großen zahl von
elemental prozess zusammensetzt seiner
menschlichen rechenkunst verschlossen
ist
das wäre jetzt eine epidemische these
der begründung der des einsatzes der
wahrscheinlichkeit gesetze wenn ich es
recht verstehe also nach dieser
auffassung weil wir eben es anders gar
nicht mehr handhaben können also das ist
jetzt hier mal die grundsituation
daneben tauchte aber schon immer eine
zweite auffassung auch für die man einen
ersten autor wohl heute wohl nicht mehr
auffinden kann die aber seit den puls
menschen bolsmann war auch ein physiker
arbeiten gewissermaßen in der luft lag
die auffassung dass umgekehrt das
geschehen im kleinen uhr
wahrscheinlichkeit medien karte hat
während durch das zusammenwirken so
viele elementare prozesse im
makroskopischen also im großen gesetze
von großer regelmäßigkeit und daher
scheinbar kausaler form entstehen
nach dieser auffassung wäre also die
qualität ein aus dem makroskopischen
physik abstrahiert der gedanke dessen
postulieren für molekulare bereich
unberechtigt und auch für die natur
erkenntnis nicht notwendig erscheint an
diese auffassung schließt sich heute die
quantenmechanik an in welcher form das
werden nur noch zu formulieren haben
also es geht hier um zwei fähren und da
sehen sie jetzt das jetzt wird die welt
etwas komplizierter wird jedenfalls aus
der sicht der wissenschaft philosophen
damit sie eben einmal so die
makroskopische ich mache das ist einfach
mal hier
der makrokosmos sage ich mal
also max heißt einfach nur groß und hier
haben wir ein kosmos heißt jetzt die
ordnung aber die große ordnung groß
systeme könnte man sagen
und hier unten seien jetzt machen wir
den mikros heißt klein mikrokosmos
ja und jetzt ist eben die frage wie
verhalten sich die zueinander
natürlich besteht der makrokosmos aus
micro kosten klar also sk wenn sie nur
genau hinschauen
dann klar dann also müsst ihr so machen
mehr oder weniger das ist sehr praktisch
damit der große lupe betrachtet also
sagen hier die große lupe
so gehen meine ganz große lupe gehen wir
in den makrokosmos in eine riesengroße
vergrößern wir gehen die feinstruktur
hinein und jetzt gibt es eben das wissen
sie alle eben diese problematik das wird
ganz bei den ganz kleinen reingehen dass
wir dann eben so was wie die kausalität
relation nicht mehr entdecken dass wir
vorfinden und dass wir nur noch von
wahrscheinlichkeit verhältnissen reden
können das beginnt schon dann wenn sie
sich den verfall den zerfall eines
radioaktiven teilchen anschauen die
können da nie genau bestimmen wann jetzt
was der fall ist und sie können nur
sagen mit dieser wahrscheinlichkeit ist
zu diesem zeitpunkt diese dieser fall
eingetreten zerfall eingetreten
aber sie können damit eigentlich nicht
mehr richtig operieren wie wir es jetzt
tun mit dingen die in unserem leser
kosmos der fall sind ich möchte jetzt
mal diese welt dazwischen den ich jetzt
einfach mal mehr so chris muss messers
heißt mitte in der mitte das ist das
sind wir
das ist ganz interessant das hat man
jemand festgestellt unserer lebenswelt
in unseren objekten als in der
größenordnung von ich weiß nicht von
einem millimeter bis vielleicht 100
meter oder sogar ein kilometer zu
unserer lebens möglichen größen mit
denen operieren
die sind wirklich
mit genau in der mitte von der größten
makroskopischen definitionen in den
kleinsten mikroskopischen benutzen also
wir sind ziemlich genau in der mitte
das ist ziemlich alle finde ich ziemlich
interessanten es sind nicht irgendwer
markus kopf kosten sondern eher
mikrokosmos sondern wir sind genau der
mitte das könnte jetzt natürlich damit
zusammenhängen dass es uns evolutionär
nur möglich ist eben bis zu einer
gewissen weise ins große so denken oder
zu schauen und bis zu einem gewissen
tiefe ins kleine zu schauen
dann würden wir mit dieser aussage über
den mikrokosmos mikrokosmen nichts über
die welt aussagen sind nun über unsere
erkenntnis kräfte die eben nur eine
bestimmte reichweite haben aber man kann
das schon auch stärker objektivieren wir
scheint tatsächlich der mitte zwischen
den allergrößten dimension diesen
größten galaxien in aller kleinsten
teilchen ja und für unseren meso kosmos
letztendlich könnte man jetzt nach einem
modernen physikalischen verständnis
sagen da spielt natürlich die kausalität
eine rolle da können wir mit so was wie
ursachen wirkungen operieren
aber wenn wir ganz ins große gehen gut
hier nach diesem zitat wird jetzt gesagt
gerade im makrokosmos geltend die kausal
gesetze ihr weil sich das ganze da er
stabilisiert hat dort bilden sich klum
kann von sternen die dann auf ganz
klaren kreisbahnen schweben dh das ganze
wird viel objektive weil sie im größeren
vollzieht und dem kleineren da wird es
dann unübersichtlich man kann aber auch
genau die entgegengesetzte auffassung
vertreten wie es im folgen zitate fall
war
ja
es ist eine gute frage ja wir würden sie
sagen dann können wir darüber
diskutieren wie verstehen sie das
[Musik]
ja also
das kann sky news
wenn er die einsätze
genau ein sehr aktiven vorherigen zitat
so etwas im vorherigen zitat
aber natürlich kann man immer zu recht
auf waren wir wie ist es dann wirklich
die welt
aber das ist ganz stark methodologische
also sind ganz starke meteorologen und
erkenntnistheorie ticker hier aber man
muss sehr wohl auch die frage nach der
unter logi auf das ist glaube ich sind
berechtigt und jetzt kommt er auf dieses
glücksspiel zu sprechen und will jetzt
ebenso wenn ich es recht verstossen
falsch falsche auffassung von
wahrscheinlichkeit hier so ein bisschen
korrigieren
er sagt es lässt sich zeigen dass die
gleiche wahrscheinlichkeit bei den
glücksspielen auf die anderen eine
stetige wahrscheinlichkeit funktion
zurückgeführt werden kann
nehmen wir etwa das roulette spielen
wenn wir annehmen dass der umdrehung
winkel des zeigers in vielfachen von 2 p
gezählt in der häufigkeit eines
vorkommens 175 eines vorkommens bei
wiederholtem los schnellen durch eine
stetige wahrscheinlich funktion
wahrscheinlichkeit zum geregelt ist so
bedeute die gliederung in rot und
schwarz sektoren eine unterteilung des
arguments der wahrscheinlichkeit
funktionen schmale gleich intervalle das
lässt sich mathematisch zeigen dass die
flächen zu mir aus dem ersten drittel
fünften original streifen mit nehrung
gleich der flächen summe aus dem 26
die nannten streifen ist und dass diese
neuerung bei gegebener
wahrscheinlichkeit zu tun umso besser
ist je schmaler die sektoren gewählt
werden
der methodische ansatz der was gleich
wahrscheinlichkeit für rot und schwarz
im roulette lässt sich also zurückführen
auf die topologische voraussetzung die
existenz einer stetigen
wahrscheinlichkeit funktion das
entsprechende gilt für alle anderen
glücksspielen als wie verstehen sie
jetzt das und wird die
wahrscheinlichkeit begründet oder
fundiert
liebe auf
auf metrische sachverhalten wir können
das ganze eben konkret ausrechnen was
die flächen anbelangt
die flächen ja
sony hat genau in der zunge genau
genau und zwei die kleiner in kleinen
tick das ganze ist oder
nicht genau
es wird fungiert sozusagen es wurde wird
fundiert in dieser fläche in dieser
mathematisch beschreibbaren summen
flächen zumindest wenn ich jetzt
natürlich genau und er sagt jetzt die
kleine den tee wallis sind desto genauer
wird das ganze
und wenn ich ein gegenmodell den
häufigkeit der cdu dann mache ich zu
sagen
also so lieben ist könnte man sich wieso
lässt das laufen auf 0,5 eben raus
beide male daneben ja genossen liebe sie
kleiner ich das machen also infiniti sie
mal rechnungen sozusagen dem integral
dann vielleicht zu von diesen flächen
wahrscheinlichkeit nicht mehr sprechen
funktion und das würde jetzt eben wieder
zeigen dass die rede von
wahrscheinlichkeit eben nicht nur eine
spielerei ist oder so eine ungenauigkeit
sind dass sich damit durchaus objektiv
operieren lässt mit dieser
wahrscheinlichkeit dafür möchte einfach
argumentieren und das kann man jetzt
eben hier an diesen hat er viele
gleichungen drin mit mit brauchen wir so
viele funktionen die man jetzt gar nicht
ausfindig machen
diskutieren müssen dass es das beispiel
was letztendlich das ganze begründet ist
wir rechnen einfach die flächen aus
damit wird das mysteriöse auftreten der
gleich wahrscheinlichkeit in den
glücksspielen als folge einer
voraussetzung aufgedeckt wie die
erkenntnistheoretischen kritik in ganz
anderen nasen zugänglich ist die
existenz stetiger wahrscheinlichkeit
funktion ist eine voraussetzung die wir
einen ganz anderen gebieten der physik
vor allem in der fehler theorie
wiederfinden
dass sie bei den glücksspielen gerade
zur gleich wahrscheinlichkeit diskreter
fälle führt liegt den besonderen
mechanismus zur apparate begründet die
so eingerichtet sind dass sie eine
stückweise abwechselnde aufteilung der
funktion bewirken die gleich
wahrscheinlichkeit enthält deshalb gar
kein besonderes erkenntnistheorie das
problem das lied filme allein die
existenz derartiger wahrscheinlichkeit
funktionen
also wir haben es damit eigentlich
ziemlich mit was objektiven zu tun wir
können jetzt eben mit dieser gleich
wahrscheinlichkeit versteht nicht
operieren wir können die aufteilen durch
die maschinen durch die
glücksspielautomaten zum beispiel können
wir jetzt diese wahrscheinlichkeiten im
wie ausnutzen
diese diese funktion ausnutzt in der
basis können wir das ganze fundieren in
solchen mathematischen betrachtungen wie
man es gesehen hat an dieser flächen aus
rechnung wenn die flächen eben genau
gleich groß wenn mir das unendlich klein
macht dann kann man das eben also ein
integral dann darstellen
für die erkenntnistheoretische
weiterführung des wahrscheinlichkeit
problems bedeutet nun die zurückführung
auf wahrscheinlichkeit funktionen einen
wesentlichen fortschritt hatte man
vorher geglaubt in wahrscheinlichkeit
gesetzen eine besondere art
gesetzlichkeit vorzufinden
die von der kausalen gesetzlichkeit der
natur folgt mit trennen ist zu lässt
sich durch heranziehen des bc der
wahrscheinlichkeit funktionen zeigen
dass diese trennung nur äußerliche art
ist das viel mehr wahrscheinlichkeit
gesetze und kausal gesetze nur
verschiedene logische aufspaltungen der
einen natur gesetzlichkeit bedeuten
wir können dies jetzt kurz begründet die
wir für eine ausführlichere darstellung
auf frühere arbeiten des verfassungs
verweisen müssen
wie kann man das jetzt versteht das ist
glaube ich die interessanteste these
hier oder eine der interessantesten
thesen wie verstehen sie da sind also
noch was die these jetzt wie verhalten
sich jetzt kausal gesetzt und
wahrscheinlichkeit gesetz oder funktion
zueinander
bezogen auf das naturgesetz wir haben es
also von drei wir haben jetzt hier mit
drei sätzen
also ein bisschen zu tun also wir haben
es jetzt mit wahrscheinlichkeit gesetzen
zu tun dann haben wir es mit der
kausalen gesetzlichkeit zu tun der natur
natürlich unternehmen auch irgendwie der
mit kausal gesetzen und werden somit
naturgesetz zu tun also drei
verschiedene arten von gesetzen und wir
hängen jetzt diese drei arten von
gesetzen
nach reichenbach zusammen was ist jetzt
jetzt endlich das wichtigste gesetz ja
genau hier also wir können jetzt hier
wir müssen uns natürlich uns noch genau
überlegen wie jetzt diese aufspaltung zu
verstehen aber wir können jetzt mehr
sagen hier naturgesetz dann mache ich
jetzt hier pause eingesetzt
die wahrscheinlichkeit gesetzt und jetzt
sagt er hier also in diesem zitat was
ich sehr zentral finde spricht er von
einer logischen als wahrscheinlichkeit
gesetzes ist es sind nur theologische
aufspaltungen die kann man sich jetzt
diese aufspaltung das ist jetzt sagen
dass hier kann man sich jetzt diese
aufspaltung vorstellen er sagt auch noch
logische aufspaltung
sie schüttelt mit dem kopf vorstand und
mainz eingesetzten profis
angeboten werden bei dem einige
notwendigkeit
verschiedene möglichkeiten klein wenig
es ist logisch wenn wir spielen wie das
machen wir doch mal konkret oder wollten
sie gerade sind jetzt in bestimmte außen
darzustellen
das prinzip der pensionist plötzlich da
sozusagen nach der gesetzesbegründung
also berechtigte frage
also 5
da sind wir raus besonders achten müssen
dass eine wahrscheinlichkeit werden
morgen kann
auf jeden fall
also würden sie das 10 okay weil ich
hatte es jetzt die als ein
sieht das doch das wird wahrscheinlich
vorsätzlich allgemeine gefertigten corsa
ist eigentlich gar nicht besetzt ist
oder das ja alles mental großen teil und
vivendi fassen
gute vorschläge zu bekommen noch
vielleicht doch wie gelesen
die logische folge man verschliesse sich
völlig einmal die möglichkeit besondere
wahrscheinlichkeit zu
die folge dieses statt darunter fallen
genau auf das induktive kommt dann noch
zu sprechen sondern weil man wenn ich
wenn wir die roten und schwarzen
sektoren des spiels als gleich
wahrscheinlich bezeichnen so machen wir
damit keine andere voraussetzung in die
natur als sie der geometrie oder
physiker macht wenn er eine
physikalische größe misst man ihm an
dass die physikalische größe umdrehung
swinkels roulette zeigers in ihrer
häufigkeit bei wiederholten realisierbar
realisierung ebenso durch eine
wahrscheinlichkeit funktion bestimmt ist
ließ der physiker macht der die länge
eine geschossen vorausberechnet hat und
seine berechnung mit wahrscheinlichkeit
riss beobachtungs resultaten vergleicht
das rätsel gleich wahrscheinlich ein
fell ist damit eine seite und seine
stelle tritt eine allgemeinere
voraussetzung die nichts anderes
bedeutet als die notwendige ergänzung
des kausal begriff prinzips alle möchte
offensichtlich dass kausal prinzip durch
das wahrscheinlichkeit prinzip ergänzen
wenn ich ihn recht verstehe hier also
wie kann man sich das jetzt konkret
vorstellen also naturgesetze wären
naturgesetze würde man zeigen zum
beispiel dass mein apfel unterfallen ist
nur dann ab darunter fallen lässt
ein beispiel
[Musik]
dass wir diesen staaten erklärten den
traktor zu viel getrunken gezeigt dass
es wahrscheinlich
[Musik]
zudem erscheinen
gegen ganz wahr zu machen
nämlich dann passiert ist
wir sehen es die anderen ja da ist noch
eine meldung dazu hat
die tatsächliche qualität die unabhängig
bleiben sollen also das ist das mehr
emotionen
manche menschen tragen und wenn man sagt
dass seitlich bereitet autorität ist
etwas was ich mit muss man ansetzen was
macht ihr größten geht um den echten
welt nicht das heißt dann müssen wir
auch die annahme trennen
die nahm also genauso wahrscheinlichkeit
in der spielwelt erzeugt jährlich gibt
sondern nur durch unsere anderen gibt es
auch einfach schon größe nicht
ausgeschlossen
das größte hat und für ein problem
dazu brauchen wir eine größere ist nicht
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass gesetze
überhaupt eine wahrscheinlichkeit diesen
event patienten und dass die parallelen
zwischen beiden
und wenn nicht
ach so ja oder wurde es mal vorlesen die
festlichkeiten strengen ursachen bekannt
sind dass sich die hefe und sicherheit
voraussagen
problem ist die ursache weiter
bekannte können nur einen abend zu
überleben das bestätigt auch freud und
in der rechten mitte abgewehrten älteren
kumpel vom gesetzlichen gewährleistung
von der küstenstadt war scheint als
anerkennung wegen der hypothese von
kausal bombay das geschäftsprinzip der
verknüpfung unserer bibliothek getestet
wird die wahrscheinlichkeit
wahrscheinlichkeit gemäße einblicken der
rest faktoren das prinzip
da wirkt jetzt so ein bisschen ergänzen
da wirkt es so als ob jetzt die
wahrscheinlichkeit theorie dieser causa
theorie also bei springt also aus hilft
so ein bisschen wenn wir nicht alle
faktoren ästhetisch
erkenntnistheoretischen finden können
ich bin eben immer auch noch ein
bisschen dran an dieser logischen
aufspaltung weil das klingt jetzt ja
nicht nur so nach aushilfe aushelfen
können so das klingt so als seien es so
äquivalente oder so oder so
gleichwertige beschreibungen der sache
verstehen sie es auch so als ich sehe
das als ökologische aufspaltung
jedenfalls muss das naturgesetz damit
die natur gesetzlichkeit damit auf
dieselbe weise erklärt werden können
durch diese abspaltung ist vielleicht
noch ein zitat und dann müssen auch zu
ende gehen jetzt kommt auch das
induktions problem zu sprechen sagt er
1983 es ist in der historischen
diskussion des induktions problems
genügend klar hervorgetreten dass es
sich hier um eine logische notwendigkeit
nicht handelt dies erkannt zu haben ist
die eigentliche leistung jungs und diese
erkenntnis ist seitdem nichts
wesentliches hinzugefügt worden
und es ist ebenfalls schon völlig jugend
deutlich gezeigt worden dass eine
begründung des induktions gesetz durch
erfahrung nicht möglich ist weil jeder
derartige schluss das gleiche gesetz auf
einer höheren stufe wieder voraussetzt
an diesen erkenntnistheoretischen das
tatbestand lässt sich nicht rütteln und
philosophisch theorien die diesen
tatbestand verkennen sind nicht
diskussionsfähig wir wollen uns im
folgenden deshalb nur mit zwei
philosophischen theorien zur klärung des
induktions problems auseinandersetzen
die unter beachtung dieses tatbestandes
entwickelt worden sind also ganz wichtig
wir kamen nochmal sagt david hughes
kritik der induktion dass wir eben aus
einer endlichen anzahl von regula riten
nicht auf eine gesetzmäßigkeit schließen
dürfen
die hat hier auch noch immer noch im
frühen zwanzigsten jahrhundert hat die
immer noch beachtung gefunden
das ist ziemlich beachtlich also jung
hat seine theorie ungefähr im jahr 1700
vielleicht 40 formuliert 17.50 rom mitte
des achtzehnten jahrhunderts und
praktisch noch 200 jahre danach ungefähr
hat diese theorie hat dieses problem des
induktions schlosses noch beachtung
gefunden
ganz kurz noch mal was sagt jetzt hier
zum schluss ist jetzt das problem des
der induktion
was jetzt noch mal dass mit dieser
gesetzlichkeit warum kann ich jetzt
induktion nicht gesetzlich formulieren
wie sieht das aus ich habe jetzt hier
also eine ähnliche zahl von ereignissen
wie nennt man das wenn wir das malheur
eine regionalität wir machen eine
ähnliche zahl von regularien in der
vergangenheit und wir kommen
wir schließen dann darauf dass dann ist
auch in der zukunft so sein wird
nehmen wir das mal rtt 1 und das drt 2
warum können wir jetzt so eine
induktionsschleife gründet tätigen warum
nicht
der grund ist der dass wir dann
voraussetzen müssten das eben die ganze
natur letztendlich also sagen wenn die
reguläre täten in der vergangenheit
stattgefunden haben dann treten sie auch
in der zukunft auf das wir voraussetzen
müssen dass sich das die natur ebenso
verfasst ist das eben diese regularien
zugelassen werden das heißt wir setzen
damit eigentlich wiederum auf einer
höheren ebene nämlich auf der der ganzen
natur ordnung wiederum ein gesetz voraus
also wir setzen nicht ein konkretes
gesetz voraus was jetzt die konkrete
regula ried betrifft sondern wir selbst
so was wie eine gleichförmigkeit der
natur voraus dass eben immer wenn eine
solche regularien auftritt daneben
aufgetreten ist das eine zukunft wenn
sie dann wieder auftreten wird das heißt
wir machen durch das induktions prinzip
eine annahme die jetzt nicht jetzt die
konkrete realität betrifft sondern die
form der bild die solche regularien erst
möglich macht und so verstehe ich jetzt
seine theorie dass er sagt das eben
dadurch
das gleiche gesetz auf einer höheren
stufe wieder vorausgesetzt werden also
dass die welt selbst gleichmäßig
geordnet ist das wird deshalb wenn wir
einmal eine bestimmte regelmäßigkeit
gemacht habe in der zukunft sie auch
annehmen können weil die welt eben
gleichmäßig nicht nur diese bestimmten
ereignissen all diese grundstruktur
genau davon können wir eben nichts
wissen wir können das eben nicht
begründen angemessen dass die welt eben
nach diesem gleichmäßigen takt
funktioniert dass wir wenn wir eben hier
mal die regularien dass die welt ist
dann gleich gepackt ist wenn wir hier
also jetzt mal wenn wir hier eine regula
ried haben das wieder mit zur beliebigen
zeitpunkten wieder machen können
das setzt voraus dass hier eben ein
grundgesetz herrscht was durch die ganze
zeit hindurch geht ja
das macht es nicht gibt 9000 bahn
geworfen
dann kann ich trotzdem bei den nächsten
und vielleicht eines extrem ist eher
wahrscheinlich
gut ja gut
gut das ist gleich ein sehr gutes
schlusswort man könnte sagen diese
wahrscheinlichkeit gesetzlichkeit ist
der horizont vor dem sich alles in der
weltliche abspielt auch wenn es jetzt
nicht regulär regularien mäßig
funktioniert aber wir wissen in letzer
hinsicht diese überwölbende logisch
gesehen von der wahrscheinlichkeit
müsste es daraufhin ausland so als eine
art horizont der es erlaubt ohne regel
regula riten auszukommen und dieses
induktions prinzip nicht anzunehmen
gleich noch eine interessante
perspektive zum schluss wir haben zum
klein wenig überzogen ich wünsche ihnen
frohe weihnachten ein gutes neues jahr
und wir werden im neuen jahr dann also
nachdem wir jetzt hier
die wahrscheinlichkeit theorie
angerissen haben uns mit den ganz
klassischen neueren texten der
qualitätsdebatte befassen vor allem mit
diesem makel john wesley mecki der
ebendiese enos kondition bedingungen
formuliert hat und dann werden wir die
teuren texte eingehen von david luiz und
von jack kim und wie sie alle heißen
dann bis im neuen jahr